So, before I go ahead and get on into
the video, I just want to say I'm still
doing bond giveaways up until the end of
the month. For every video that I do,
I'll be giving away a bond. So, if you
guys want to be entered into those
giveaways, just make sure to leave your
RS name in a comment down below, like
the video, and be subscribed to the
channel. With that said, the winner from
last giveaway was Drew N., so
congratulations to you, man. And thank
you for the comment. On top of that, I
will be streaming live on Twitch after
this video goes live. So, if you guys
want to check it out, feel free to hit
up the link in the description. So,
let's go ahead and get on into it. I'm
just going to try to show you guys this
as plain and simple as I can make it.
It's supposed to be a really efficient
and really quick money-making method
that you can do daily. So, that's just
what it is, and I'm going to show it.
So, blood runes lately have gone down to
190 GP there. I mean, 195 right now in
the GE, but trust me, you can buy them
for lower if you buy and sell the margin
to see what it is. As you guys can see,
I bought some earlier. I think that was
yesterday actually for 191. And then,
uh, I bought some today for 190. Yeah,
30,000. So, that was in overnight. I had
another 30,000 on the other account. And
so, really, you can get 10 GP margins on
Blood Runes right now. I don't know why
that is because you can also sell these
to a guy for 200 GP in Alcarid. He's
he's right here and there are some
requirements. So, you are obviously
going to need money to be able to buy
what however many blood runes you want.
You can buy 60,000 a day cuz of 4hour
limits. But you are also going to have
to have done the feud quest and
completed part of the mini quest to
unlock the rune store from this guy.
Once you have that done, it's not really
that bad of a quest. It should be a
relatively early requirement for most
people, so you should be able to have it
done. It should take like 30 seconds
maybe for you to find out what the price
of blood rune is and then be able to put
in an offer for 60,000. If you can't put
in an offer for 60,000, obviously you
can just buy less and then teleport to,
you know, Algrid as you please. If with
whatever amount of blood runs you may
have, you know, 2,000 3,000 doesn't
really matter. The trips are really
quick. I mean, he's right here and
you're running from over here. It's not
too hard. There's only one guy here
trading him, which is weird. I thought
there'd be a lot of bots here doing
this, but apparently not. I guess really
all you would need would be a lot of
accounts to buy all the blood runes. So
that's really the only thing holding you
back. And as I seemingly switch over to
another account with your requirements,
as you guys can see, once you go ahead
and talk to Ali Morrison, you can just
kind of talk to him a little bit and
then you can find out that there's a
shop that he has that you can sell runes
to. Oh my god, he doesn't have it done
either. Jesus Christ. All right, so I
went ahead and just finished off the
requirement on my own account. It's not
that hard. All you have to do is talk to
him, then go and talk to Aubrey and
Barack, then come back, talk to him, and
finish the Sedoku puzzle. I tried to do
it on my own once and I failed. So, uh,
it took me a little longer than should
have. But for some reason, there's a lot
of runes in here. Obviously, blood runes
as we saw earlier. That does make sense
cuz 200 per one obviously going to
profit. But the kind of weird thing that
I'm seeing here is All right, that
doesn't make any sense why this stuff
would be in here. I don't know why
anyone would sell this. Soul runes 150.
Let's see what they're worth. Well, I
guess we can just check and see here in
a second. It doesn't really make any
sense why there's a ton of every rune in
there. I guess it just might Oh,
actually soul runes
profitable. Yeah, you make you make 9 GP
with soul runes as well. Oh my gosh. All
right, so if you make 9 GP with soul
runes, too, that means All right, so
soul runes are going to be worth it
along with bloods as well. The other
ones don't really look worth it. The law
runes, they definitely Yeah, obviously
not 120. Those really don't seem to be
worth it, but bloods and souls right now
really do. I don't know why, but they're
both 10GP under. So really, this doubles
how much you can make, which is insane.
I didn't even think that there would be
other runes that would be this low. But
yeah, soul runes right now. Apparently
low enough to make it really really
profitable. And uh I guess as we can
see, I'll go ahead and show you guys how
quick this actually does take me to go
ahead and finish off. So all right, so
just go to buy non-elemental runes and
then you can sit here and just spam
click sell 50. And uh yeah, that's
literally about it. As you guys can see,
I've already sold, you know, 600 and it
took me a second. So I'm going to go
ahead time myself, see how long it
takes, and then we're going to see how
much money you could really make. All
right, and here we go. So, that is it.
Where is my timer at? This took me about
20 seconds to set up my mic, too. So,
just keep that in mind. But, yeah,
there's my timer. It took me 4 minutes
and 37 seconds. And that really I mean,
and it also took me like 15 seconds to
set up my mic. So, a little bit over 4
minutes in total to be able to do this.
Say 5 minutes in total being able to put
in the GE offers, too. Now, if you
consider that you can also do soul
runes, that takes it up to really 10
minutes a day, I guess, you could do
this method for, considering you'd also
be able to buy 60,000 soul runes. So,
let me go to the GE and just check to
make sure soul prices are about 140 GP
cuz that could be a huge game changer.
If we head on over to the GE, as you
guys can see, soul runes currently 141
even for an instaby, which means these
are definitely going to be profitable
since you can sell them for 150 no
matter what.
136. These were literally Okay, so this
is even better profit. So, that that's
insane. I didn't even know this. I wish
I would have known cuz then I could have
tested them both, but I don't have
another day to go ahead and get soul
runes. So, so runes absolutely insane,
too. If I go ahead and do some math real
quick, I can get you guys the daily
stats on these things. So, if I go ahead
and just do a little bit of math, as you
guys saw, you were able to profit 10 GP
for each blood rune that you did and
able to profit 14 GP for each soul rune
that you do. Now, in total, that's going
to be 24 GP per both runes combined
really. And you can do 60,000 runes a
day because of GE limits. This is 1.4 to
almost 1.5 mil. And it literally only
takes 10 minutes. the requirements are
really low in the fact that you only
need one quest and be able to complete
one mini quest and you'll be able to
make almost 1.5 mil in as little as 10
minutes. So, this is absolutely insane.
Way better method than I thought it was
going to be and hopefully you guys can
make as much money as you can off of it
because runes typically have a lot of
stock in the GE. So, I don't know how
easy the prices are going to go back up.
So, hopefully you guys can take
advantage of this as much as possible.
And hopefully you guys enjoyed the
video. It's definitely one that was
insane. Like I just I didn't expect this
to be this good at all. I just saw the
room prices. Well, actually, someone
mentioned in my CC the room prices were
really low and so I had to check them
out. Speaking of the CC, make sure to
join Speaking of the CC, make sure to
join large EXP lamp with two E. On top
of that, if you guys enjoyed the video,
make sure to leave a like and comment
your RSN down below to be entered in the
giveaway. On top of that, if you guys
want to see more content as soon as it
comes out in the future, make sure to
subscribe as well. But with that said,
hopefully you guys have a wonderful